bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine du 7 8 l'actu sur TVfil 78 le
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
de ce lundi de juin mortalité en baisse
sur les routes mais vigilant on se
toujours 2000 principalement vers les
usagers les plus exposés motars et
piétons nous en parlerons avec Jean-yves
petit directeur du comité des Yvelines
et de la prévention routière la ville
des Clayes-sous-Bois célèbre 50 ans de
jumelage avec l'Allemagne la commune
liée à Rothenbach depuis 1964 vient de
célébrer l'événement à quelques jours
des commémorations internationales du
débarquement du 6 juin 44 des victimes
du conflit en Ukraine viennent en France
afin de recevoir des soins médicaux
parfois très lourds l'initiative pilotée
par des associations locales dans les
Yvelines vous entendrez plusieurs
témoignages dans ce journal
mais pour débuter des images de la ville
de plaisir ou la mère Joséphine Colemann
Berger a décidé de lancer la récré à mon
suite à la décision du ministre de
l'Éducation de maintenir la réforme des
rythmes scolaires pour 2014 dès la
rentrée la pause du midi sera rallongée
de 15 minutes et chaque jour de 16h à
16h30 une plage de récréation
supplémentaire baptisée donc la
récréation sera mise en place juste
avant à l'étude une façon pour l'élu de
réaffirmer son opposition à cette
réforme elle dénonce toujours je cite un
chantage inadmissible et une menace
insupportable de l'État elle viendra par
ailleurs sur notre plateau mardi 18h30
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 société
elle participera un débat présenté par
Catherine zulato rediffusion le soir
même 19h30 et 23h et puis à noter aussi
que demain la contestation sur le
terrain se poursuivra à Maurepas alors
que le conseil municipal doit voter vers
19h ça délibération sur le texte des
nouveaux rythmes c'est le maire qui
appelle à rejoindre au même moment
devant l’hôtel de ville la manifestation
des gilets jaunes nous en parlerons bien
sûr dans une la chaîne édition où en
est-on de la sécurité routière en France
des résultats ont été annoncés récemment
par le gouvernement une nouvelle fois de
la mortalité régresse 3268 personnes ont
perdu la vie en 2013 10,5% de moins
qu'en 2012 mais cela reste trop malgré
tout bonsoir Jean-Yves petit et bienvenu
directeur du comité des Yvelines de la
prévention routière je donnais la
situation dans les grandes lignes sur
l'hexagone quelle est la situation dans
le département pour l'année 2013 déjà
alors pour l'année 2013 nous avons eu
dans le département des Yvelines nous
déplorons 47 tués ce qui est quasiment
la même chose quand il est en 2012
puisqu'il y avait eu 48t donc 48 fait
pardon donc une stagnation de ce point
de vue là le nombre de blessés avait
diminué mais globalement il y avait pas
eu de grandes différences entre 2012 et
2013 dans notre département en tout cas
il y a pas de d'aggravation du phénomène
les gens sont pas
eu d'aggravation non plus on va venir
plus en détail sur ces différents
chiffres ce sera juste après ce clip qui
nous rappelle qu'une erreur au volant ne
par donne pas
tant qu'il y aura trop d'alcool dans le
sang d'un conducteur il y aura du sang
sur les routes tant qu'un conducteur
rattra un virage parce qu'il n'a pas
voulu rater un appel on appellera une
ambulance
tant qu'un véhicule de trois tonnes
ignorance
il y aura des tonnes de dégâts
tant qu'on tournera sans faire attention
à l'angle mort il y aura des morts dans
l'angle mort tant que la vitesse
inscrite sur les compteurs dépassera
celle inscrite sur les panneaux les
accidents ne ralentiront pas tant qu'on
continuera à penser que ce sont les
autres qui conduisent mal sans penser
que les autres c'est nous tous tant
qu'on ne comprendra pas que le code de
la route n'est pas là pour nous faire
perdre des points de permis mais pour
nous faire gagner des années de vie tant
qu'il y aura des morts il nous faudra
agir pour une route plus sûre
tous responsables de la sécurité
routière
le directeur du comité des Yvelines de
la prévention routière on vient de voir
l'un des spots de sensibilisation qui
met notamment en scène des usagers dit
fragiles ce sont les motards aujourd'hui
ce sont vers eux que les messages
s'adressent principalement est-ce que
sur la route les motards sont aussi plus
touchés
le film est excellent le petit film
qu'on vient de voir je le connaissais il
est excellent les motards sont très
touchés oui mais les messages de
prévention s'adressent à tout le monde
les motards ne sont pas les seuls
usagers d'y vulnérables les usagers
vulnérables c'est sont aussi les piétons
et les cyclistes
donc les messages de prévention oui
s'adresse au motard qui paie un lourd
tribu aux accidents de la route on sait
très bien qu'il y a une surreprétation
des tués et des accidentés dans les deux
roues motorisés par rapport à l'ensemble
du trafic c'est ça je vous posez cette
question justement lorsqu'on regarde les
chiffres même sur 2013 5,2 % des usagers
et des deux roues motorisés ont perdu la
vie et ils ne portaient pas de casque
5,2% de portait pas de casque ça semble
aller de soi et pourtant le message ne
passe pas on ne met pas de casque sur la
route ça veut dire qu'il y en a quand
même
95% qui porte le casque bon
qu'est-ce que vous voulez il y a
toujours des gens qui ne mettent pas de
casque toujours des gens qui n'aident
pas de ceinture en voiture l'équipement
adapté aussi ça c'est important parce
que si le casque ça va de soi on voit
souvent les motards ils prennent
peut-être moins oui c'est vrai que ce
soit sur les bras sur les jambes alors
je pense en particulier à tous les les
personnes qui vont travailler en scooter
et qui sont habillés comme moi
aujourd'hui
en particulier vous voyez pas mes
chaussures mais qui ont les chaussures
de ville ce qui est évidemment pas
recommandé pour faire du scooter les
chevilles sont très fragiles donc il est
recommandé d'avoir de la même façon
qu'on porte des gants il est recommandé
d'avoir des chaussures montantes et
fermées vous parlez tout à l'heure des
autres usagers des fragiles sur la route
quel message il faut leur adresser c'est
aussi lorsqu'on fait du vélo lorsqu'on
est cycliste faire attention aux autres
alors sur les voitures font attention
mais exactement qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un usager vulnérable déjà puisque
c'est la Quinzaine des usagers
vulnérables première quinzaine de juin
pour moi un usager vulnérable et
quelqu'un qui est mal vu
et quelqu'un qui n'a pas de carrosserie
pour le protéger donc les piétons
évidemment ils sont pas toujours bien vu
surtout la nuit évidemment et aucune
carrosserie les vélos et ont pas
beaucoup de carrosserie ils ont un
casque s'ils en métin on sait que c'est
pas obligatoire et les motards c'est
pareil la seule carrosserie qu'ils ont
c'est le casque quand ils le portent
donc c'est ça pour moi un usager
vulnérable rendre obligatoire le casque
justement pour les vélos alors peut-être
que ça viendra mais c'est déjà
obligatoire dans les clubs de
Cyclotourisme mais toutes les courses
cyclistes le casque est obligatoire dans
le Tour de France on les voit ils
portent tous le casque maintenant alors
qu'il y a je sais pas combien 4 ou 5 ans
peut-être c'était pas encore obligatoire
donc on progresse dans ce sens là la
plupart des accidents graves en vélo
même s'ils sont pas mortels sont dus à
des traumatismes crâniens un casque en
éviterait certainement beaucoup on
évoquait tout à l'heure les meilleurs
résultats 2013 sur la sécurité routière
seulement début 2014 la courbe semble
s'inverser plus 7% de tuer sur les
quatre premiers mois de l'année au
niveau national comparé à la même
période de l'an dernier comme on peut
expliquer cette cet aggravation qui ne
se confirme pas dans le département en
revanche alors oui les chiffres
nationaux je sais pas comment on peut
les expliquer il y a toujours une
explication que l'on donne c'est la
météo quand il fait beau il y a plus de
monde sur les routes on va plus vite on
fait moins attention plus de piétons
plus de cycliste plus de motards donc
malheureusement plus d'accident les
autres raisons au niveau national je
vous que je peux pas bien le dire je
sais même pas si on peut les expliquer
pour l'instant mais dans l'autre
département à nous
et ça non plus j'explique pas réellement
c'est à l'inverse 30% d'accidents
mortels en moins par rapport à la même
période de 2013 les 5 premiers mois de
l'année j'ai pas les chiffres enfin
j'espère qu'il y a pas eu de tuer mais
sur le week-end de l'Ascension que nous
venons de vivre j'ai aucune information
pour l'instant à ce sujet et les causes
sont toujours les mêmes alcool vitesse
non port de la ceinture également sont
un message évident mais qu'il faut
chaque année répéter surtout à la veille
des départs en vacances d'été bientôt
aujourd'hui quel est le message aussi
que vous souhaitez faire passer auprès
des pouvoirs publics est-ce qu'il faut
plus de contrôle on l'a vu sur le
département des Yvelines dans d'autres
départements aussi ces voitures radars
qui ont été installés est-ce que c'est
une bonne chose est-ce qu'il faudrait
encore d'autres dispositifs
la répression
à une place
incontournable c'est évident alors si on
pouvait avoir plus de radars plus de
voitures plus de policiers c'est évident
que ça serait bien de ce point de vue là
mais bon faut être raisonnable il y a
aussi la prévention que nous faisons que
la police et la gendarmerie font aussi
plus les polices municipales bien sûr
mais tout ça forme un tout mais je
voulais ajouter si vous permettez sur
les usagers vulnérables vous parliez des
des erreurs qui sont toujours les mêmes
mais il faut savoir que les cyclistes et
les piétons commettent eux aussi des
erreurs et ce sont toujours les mêmes
les erreurs dues à l'alcool du Aline
attention dû à la drogue due au non
respect du code de la route puisque les
cyclistes et les piétons sont soumis
aussi au code de la route donc les
piétons et les cyclistes commettent les
mêmes infractions que les que les
voitures ou que les motards ils en sont
évidemment plus victimes parce qu'ils
sont pas protégés on va faire une pause
avec un micro-trottoir à présent
qu'avez-vous changé ou non d'ailleurs
dans votre comportement sur la route
c'est notre question du jour
moi par rapport au début je voulais
beaucoup plus vite quand j'ai mon permis
je voulais beaucoup plus vite et puis au
fil des années je me suis calmé donc je
roule j'espère plus les limitations de
vitesse maintenant qu'avant
je remarqué que les gens au moins vite
sur l'autoroute depuis quelle heure à
l'heure automatique
globalement avant quand on roule à 130
on était régulièrement doublé et
maintenant
à 130 on double je sais pas moi pour
personnellement je pense avoir toujours
été prudente maintenant avec les
diminutions de vitesse tout ça oui je
fais beaucoup plus attention
évolution donc évolution oui peut-être
de ralentir un petit peu plus
effectivement sur sur le périph ou sur
les axes on va dire plutôt communaux
voilà parce que on est quand même un
petit peu plus limité un petit peu plus
contrôlé donc on lève un petit peu le
pied effectivement
en fait effectivement ce qui a changé
récemment c'est qu'on fait un peu plus
attention au radar donc clairement on
lève un peu le pied
voilà maintenant à long terme je sais
pas si c'est vraiment efficace en tout
cas en terme de comportement routier
c'est sûr que on fait un peu plus
attention à la vitesse les gens qui font
attention à la vitesse ça au moins c'est
sûr il y a cette discussion aussi
actuellement autour de la réduction sur
le réseau secondaire de 90 à 80 km/h
est-ce que vous êtes favorable ce serait
une bonne chose les discussions qui ont
été reportées plutôt vers le mois de
juin alors que c'est des décisions
étaient attendues pour mais alors déjà
un petit commentaire sur le film je sais
pas si le montage a été fait exprès pour
mais ça n'a parlé que de vitesse non ce
sont les réactions des gens
effectivement ce qui reviennent plus
souvent c'est vraiment ça qui revient la
chose que nous souhaitons à la
prévention routière c'est que toutes les
voitures neuves qui sortent des usines
soit équipées d'un régulateur limiteur
de vitesse après les gens s'en servent
vous ne s'en servent pas c'est comme ils
veulent mais ça coûte certainement pas
très cher et très utile et c'est très
utile
alors
concernant la limitation de vitesse
personnellement je n'y suis pas
favorable
d'une façon généralisée parce que la
mutation de on a suffisamment
limitations de vitesse
la limitation de vitesse à 90 quand elle
est respectée et généralement suffisante
maintenant il y a des endroits qui
mériteraient largement d'être limité à
70 je l'ai déjà dit sur votre plateau je
crois j'avais roulé en Corse l'été
dernier les départementales sont limités
à 90 on peut pas dépasser le 60 dans cet
état de route de montagne sauf les
Corses qui connaissent peut-être mais il
y a certains endroits qui mériteraient
très certainement d'être limités à 70
km/h mais diminuer la vitesse d'une
façon unilatérale partout à 80 km/h je
n'y suis personnellement pas favorable
et notre association verrait plutôt des
réductions sont ciblées dans les
endroits dangereux on va profiter de
votre présence pour terminer très
rapidement sur cette opération de
sensibilisation que vous mettez en place
chaque année dans les écoles est-ce que
vous pouvez nous représenter ce
dispositif qui touche les classes de CM2
du secteur et un dispositif dont la
finale se déroulera le 7 juin à oudans
oui en deux mots alors il s'agit
d'éducation routière les bénévoles les
bénévoles de l'association du comité
les gendarmes les policiers municipaux
educs les enfants de CM2 essentiellement
mais aussi un peu plus jeunes
à l'autonomie sur la voie publique en
particulier à vélo en CM2 c'est l'âge où
on commence à faire du vélo tout seul
sur la voie publique donc nous leur
apprenons à faire du vélo le maniement
du vélo et les règles du code de la
route adaptées à l'orage chaque enfant
qui passe enfin chaque classe qui passe
entre nos mains
sélectionne le meilleur élève de chaque
classe et
les meilleurs compétitions pour
absolument et les meilleurs
retrouve à la fin de l'année scolaire
donc ça aura lieu cette année le samedi
7 juin à Houdan une fois de plus pour un
challenge de la prévention routière qui
porte essentiellement sur le vélo merci
Jean-Yves petit directeur du comité des
Yvelines de la prévention routière
d'être venu en plateau nous faisions
avec vous le bilan de cette année 2013
plutôt bon alors que le début 2014
semble marqué par l'inversion de la
tendance ou du moins au niveau national
et pas dans le département des Yvelines
quelques autres chiffres à présent ceux
du chômage communiqué par Pôle emploi
pour le mois d'avril sur la région
Île-de-France 637 630 demandeurs
d'emploi et de première catégorie une
progression de 0,1% en un mois mais
surtout de 5,6% sur un an dans les
Yvelines la demande est plus forte
encore plus 0,7% en un mois globalement
ce sont les seniors les plus touchés à
noter enfin que les offres d'emploi sont
moins nombreuses sur les trois dernières
mois toujours sur la région moins 18%.
donc quelques jours nous fêterons les 70
ans du débarquement du 6 juin 44 avant
de se replonger dans l'horreur de la
guerre aux Clayes-sous-Bois on a fait le
choix de célébrer le jumelage avec
l'Allemagne 50e anniversaire des liens
et qui unissent la ville à celle de
Rothenbach Olivier Maniscalco et
Jonathan Wilman
un demi-siècle d'amitié en triveline et
Bavière ce week-end la ville des clés
sous bois fêtait le 50e anniversaire de
son jumelage avec Rothenbach une commune
de 12000 âmes situées au sud de
l'Allemagne une histoire qui a débuté en
1964 par une signature entre deux élus
français et allemand lors d'une journée
dont se souvient Michel Mathieu alors
âgé de 28 ans particulièrement
impressionné par le maire bavarois
dehors
le entre deux gros claques qui
n'existent plus maintenant on avait
installé des tables et siégait le maire
de rotenbach et le maire des clercs avec
le adjoint
et j'étais venu par curiosité
parce que je parlais un peu allemand et
là
ce qui m'a le plus marqué comme je
l'expliquais c'est le discours d'une
mère allemande qui disait des propos qui
tenaient des propos vraiment gentils
pour le jumelage etc mais avec une voix
forte et faisant des gestes énormes si
bien que certaines personnes dans les
gens qui étaient présents ont dit ça y
est les bouches reviennent ils ont pensé
à Hitler tout à fait parce que moi j'ai
des souvenirs d'enfance d'avoir entendu
Hitler il ne parlait pas il hurlait il
gueulait
et ça pour les personnes qui étaient là
qui étaient beaucoup plus âgées que moi
ça ça il y a eu un frisson qui est passé
dans l'assemblée aujourd'hui bien plus
détendu grâce notamment à ce type de
jumelage les relations franco-allemand
de permettent tout au long de l'année de
nombreux échanges entre les deux
communes et parfois même un peu plus il
y a énormément d'échanges tout au long
de l'année on a des échanges avec les
pompiers de Rothenbach et les pompiers
ici des échanges avec les sportifs on a
une association qui est extrêmement
impliquée également dans les échanges
c'est des liens il y a même certains que
les chiens qui se sont mariés avec des
Allemands qui habitent à rotenbach 150
habitants de Rothenbach ont fait le
déplacement pour ses festivités dont le
maire Klaus hacker un maire chanteur et
bassiste du groupe Rainbow All Star Band
qui jouait samedi pour l'occasion
deux informations politiques à vous
communiquer à tout d'abord la création
d'un groupe écologiste à Aiguillon court
au sein du conseil municipal bien que
membre de la majorité PS les élus Europe
Écologie Les Verts ont décidé d'affirmer
leurs différences sur les questions de
démocratie participative de
réchauffement climatique ou encore des
talons urbains de la commune elle est VR
qui rappelle cependant qu'il ne s'agit
là que d'une manière d'enrichir le
projet de la gauche sur cette commune et
puis à La Verrière le maire communiste
allant à jage s'est exprimé au lendemain
des résultats des européennes il déplore
la montée du Front national l'abstention
également mais parle d'un phénomène
prévisible au regard de la situation
actuelle en France et notamment dans sa
ville il annonce vouloir proposer à
chacun un citoyen comme élu de se
retrouver et de débattre sans pour
l'instant donner plus de précision des
victimes ukrainiennes présentant en
France pour des opérations parfois
lourdes c'est l'une de leurs
compatriotes installées dans les
Yvelines qui se charge de leur venue et
nous avons rencontré deux blessés de
jeunes étudiants atteints lors d'une
manifestation au début de la crise
c'était en février dernier Yolaine
Torres et Yves stenberger
et vas-y ils sont Ukrainiens ils sont
venus en France pour se faire opérer
tous les deux ont perdu un œil lors
d'une manifestation chez eux à qui avant
le 18 février dernier ce jour-là les
forces de l'ordre avait pour mission de
débarrasser la place des manifestants
une place administrative très
stratégique en Ukraine
je voulais sortir dans la rue pour
montrer qu'on est un peuple qui défend
ses droits pas seulement un petit groupe
de mécontents
mécontents de notre gouvernement et nous
ne sommes pas seulement un groupe muscul
on veut défendre nos droits en tant que
jeune nous voulons faire tes études
avoir un travail et vivre correctement
la moitié des gens étaient blessée
chaque minute quelqu'un tombait à ma
gauche à ma droite je n'ai pas pu
compter peut-être 1000 personnes
peut-être 1000 ou 2000 je ne sais pas
presque tout le monde était touché
les deux étudiants ont déjà subi deux
opérations une première dans leur pays
où on leur a retiré leur œil blessé puis
en Lettonie ici en France on leur a mis
une prothèse pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à vivre normalement une
opération financée principalement par
des Ukrainiens basé au Canada
Liana panazévitch banquet Versailles
d'origine ukrainienne s'occupe de leur
prise en charge en France la France un
pays qu'ils ont découvert un peu plus
pendant leur séjour ils en ont même
profité pour visiter le château de
Versailles
je vois la France comme un pays où tu as
le droit de travailler de faire des
études ici tu peux faire des études tu
peux travailler te reposer en Ukraine
ces différents chaque jour tu ne vis pas
vraiment mais tu travailles pour
survivre avant tout
au lendemain des élections européennes
et d’une déferlante dite eurosceptique
Oleg futur avocat comme il l'espère
croient en Europe
est un pays unique et non pas simplement
plusieurs pays réunis
avec beaucoup de valeurs et où les
hommes sont libres
a eu de la chance elle s'est développée
et n'a jamais été dans l'État soviétique
ils vont pouvoir retrouver leur famille
dans quelques jours lorsqu'ils seront
enfin guéris la cellule médicale qui les
a pris en charge vient de décider de
monter une association parmi leurs
missions et de les blessés Ukrainiens à
se faire opérer en France apporter
ensuite de l'aide humanitaire en Ukraine
et aider les réfugier de Crimée des
collectes de fonds sont organisés
Artisans du Monde pionnier dans le
secteur du commerce équitable organise
régulièrement des opérations de
sensibilisation un peu partout en France
40 ans après sa création elle s'est
militants de l'agriculture paysanne se
font toujours entendre alors que la
crise alimentaire frappe les populations
les plus démunies Mathilde cabernes et
Olivier Maniscalco se sont rendus dans
une des boutiques de la marque à Trappes
au coin d'un croisement à deux pas d'un
supermarché l'une des 170 boutiques
d'artisans du monde c'est implanté à
Trappes Artisans du Monde réseau
associatif de distribution assure un
commerce équitable le commerce équitable
c'est un partenariat qui est basé sur le
respect des gens la transparence des
prix et le respect de l'environnement
les producteurs sont payés un prix qui a
été négocié entre les deux parties et
qui correspond à ce qu'ils ont besoin
pour couvrir leurs frais pour assurer un
niveau de vie correct suivant le pays où
ils sont pour pouvoir éduquer leurs
enfants les envoyer à l'école et ne pas
être obligé de les faire travailler
et qui leur permettent aussi de
respecter leur environnement c'est à
dire de ne pas produire dans des
conditions qui qui détruisent leur mode
de vie Afrique Asie du Sud-Est ou encore
Amérique du Sud mille et une couleur et
mille et une forme se partagent les
comptoirs du point de vente un concept
apprécié par les clients comme Patrick
qui volontairement vient de Bois d'Arcy
pour soutenir la démarche de
l'association le geste solidaire c'est
de permettre aux
gens des pays du Sud de vivre beaucoup
mieux et de vivre notamment de leur
production ce qui est très important ça
leur permet notamment de rester chez eux
plutôt que de les obliger à venir chez
nous pour gagner leur vie
Artisans du Monde à trois moyens
d'action la vente de produits
l'éducation aux commerces équitable et
les campagnes de promotion à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'antenne
compte une quarantaine de bénévoles
fin de ce journal du 2 juin mardi nous
parlerons de cette nouvelle application
pour téléphone portable lancé par
l'association yvelinoise HF prévention
où trouver des préservatifs quels sont
elle est chose à savoir pour s'en servir
plus généralement des renseignements
pratiquent sur la sexualité marraine de
cette application qui vient d'être
lancée c'est Marina Carrère d'Encausse
qui intervient auprès du journal de la
santé sur France 5 nous en parlerons
demain avec les responsables de
l'association reportage complet aussi
lors du lancement officiel cette fois-ci
à demain donc et n'oubliez pas notre
site Internet pour les Replay et les
réseaux sociaux pour nous suivre 24
heures sur 24 bonne soirée